hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike my Hardy
here with Justin hey Walt how's it going
and tim schafer egg rice hello from
Double Fine we are gonna close out this
year Wednesday by playing a few games
from Double Fine and then getting a look
at second house - if I'm not mistaken a
little bit cool the new rounds all right
I'm excited uh G games sweet so what say
we jump right in where we playing first
Greg we got two bullets here right so we
develop our own games like second let's
tube we also publish games and do things
with double fine presents and find Greg
finds the best and most amazing games
out there indie games like couplets
yeah we're getting to gang beefs and
knights and bikes a little bit too lots
to show this is just a two-person team
okay Rebecca and then glum Burland
okay and put together this awesome game
about its town sim but also a little bit
of a Pokemon style RPG and farming all
the things you love together Justin a
ball is good action there I ain't never
game before oh yeah the blitz themselves
are kind of the things you collect and
they are so adorable and they are
adorable and you can make them fight
mm-hmm which is what you want to do with
adorable and they don't get hurt yeah so
Justin does you let them fight in the
winter if you win the fight you get a
seed from that bit you can take home and
plant in your farm you'll see that later
okay you first get to your town one you
can meet a lot of different people and
you can see who you want to be friends
with in which it's a club do you want to
join they're not gangs okay their club
and each club has its own flavor this is
not there's an adventure clubs out in
the world in the woods and this is the
name of this the front the front bun
front buns they have their own style and
each when you the significance of it is
besides the fact they have their own
styles that you get a first boob late--
which starts you on your collection okay
and there's a lot of dancing in this
game so these get this is not an
isolated incidents of dancing no there
is so much dancing that's what happens
when you buy a mocap rig dance party and
then a lot of dance in the guy I've
learned a lot about dancing from playing
this game did I prefer to do any of the
dancing mocap for this is this it or any
of these your moves so
no I like to imagine Ben and Rebecca
doing it on though just dancing in the
corner astly dancing every character is
constantly moving and dancing the game I
feel like it'd be impossible to be in a
bad mood any time I play this hmm now
what this is a like a outfit shop it is
and and a hairdresser two and one
you can customize your player character
your look you will get a house that
you'll get to buy furniture for and
decorate any way you want Justin and
then green jammies mm-hmm and then uh
you can get get into all these clothes
and also your hairstyle I try to
convince my bosses to let me wear my
pajamas on stage tomorrow I mean you
want they want you to be comfortable
right hey I guess you don't know the
process this isn't going to Japanese
really we've never done bald before oh
man okay sit oh no oh man yep like
whipped cream that just became a an old
man exclusive second gamespot exclusive
baldness I think the ball goes with
green jammies and so that's not based on
gender you can have any kind of haircut
you want whether you're a man or land it
anything you want I like to run
animation yep the spring - Robbie rifle
- oh my god just looks elite it goes
grandpa
let's go actually get a new bullet yeah
so that's our where you mentioned it's
kinda like a Pokemon RPG are that what's
the pseudo Pokemon in this case these
are the full-on new blades okay they're
uh the little creatures that roam wild
in this world yeah um and your this is
Greg's favorite um sprouts that's right
mm-hmm and join and you get your first
you get a badge and you get first oh you
get a Shrum bow
mm-hmm new friend yay nice mm-hmm
in case your pajamas weren't adorable
enough you get from bow which is a
terrifying warrior of the Oh boots world
mushroom warrior they're all pretty tiny
little right are there any that get a
bigger they all meant to be kind of
friendly pet sized berry and they said
to follow you around a little kasi well
that would be a noob gonna do but even
the please venerable in the world of
make sense he would have stopped you
would not let you get out if he didn't
have a new blip we don't yo get to go
out in the world with
but okay my endurance out there yeah
it's dangerous as you'll see in a second
you might get jumped by any sort of
dangerous creature
look how shrimper just is dying to fight
uh-oh clicky clacks they just double
zero you're not making them fight they
just love to fight there is going to
dirts class new poop mm-hmm only in
desperation good take that please Claus
no we got a snoop Boop yeah cooldown
timer on it who's run away ah victory
how nice
yep and now you get to eat their corpse
I'm not good to demo in this game is
terrible they're not what it's about
that don't kid eat any corpses he runs
away other way but you got a seed which
you can now plant
okay the farm you go to the farm farm
mm-hmm and then will you grow boo butts
okay oh and I'm into it
that's an awesome move it looks like a
brain and Jill gelatin moving legs
gloopy so you're gonna get the tools
that you need this junk those are seeds
to actually grow food to feed your bliss
to so I got a love Paula flower yeah low
poly flour I think oh yeah so that's how
you like get new abilities for your
blitz and upgrade them over time but
we're gardening now my little hoe so how
did you guys did discover this game and
then decide to be the publisher for it
Greg fanned on Twitter thank everybody's
seen eating on Twitter these days she
posts a lot of really cute little gifts
on her on a feed at non-player kat and
it's hard to resist the cuteness factor
of the Blitz yeah but yeah I mean like I
also read the description it's like it's
like Animal Crossing Harvest Moon and
Pokemon I'm like those are all some of
my favorite things that's the headline
for this video yeah
from clicky claws so I'm assuming it'll
grow a clicky claws it will and if
there's a day/night cycle and everything
this is like little tutorial sections so
kind of skip through that but yeah over
time you'd have to tend to your garden
into the weeds water your plants and
grow its foods
there's your rooms you get to customize
later yes or it'll be just like the just
like the clothing store they'll be
furniture stores and things like that
would be a baffle arrange your your room
and these things for you or your summer
me so I just got a new top here my pink
and purple raincoat but yeah then I also
have some what stuff Oh God
my shrimp Oh got a new hat I noticed the
Santa hat festive very festive got but
now I got some some grown-up lit plants
out here very enthusiastic the people of
this town up what could that be uh it's
like a claw a very own clicky claws yes
nice so grumpy cookie o'clock and these
would be plants then that would feed
into the grid system for your Shrum Bo
okay I think this is just barely enough
to let me upgrade and give him a new
move goose whirly the goose whirly so
we'd be able to now kind of head off
down the trail to other locations and
fight more battles and work our way
there okay
that's like we have really showed much
up so we do have some new new worlds we
can jump into as well yeah definitely
yeah we just so know we're downstairs on
kind of funny but we haven't shown this
one yet so this is in a desert area mo
muna
yeah I don't think I've seen this one
probably not so yeah there'll be a whole
new set of boots out here on both the
fight and train who's not where'd you
get that guy
you haven't me into a new character
because I just restarted because our new
set of boob lips form Emunah here that's
the park ride would have gone for mm-hmm
oh that wasn't you that was virgin he
talked to us cuz that you're just aged
like 20 years as well mhm you now have a
different like up what's called an ohm
hair okay mmm
boomba Umbra got some suit suiting ups
if the devs talked about how how big
like what kind of they're going for with
the game like this I mean it's early in
development right so we'll see we'll see
it's it's she's moving crazy quick it's
insane how there'll be new things in the
game every time we look at it so yeah it
still a ways off probably it's coming
later in 2018 but yeah I think that
Rebecca doing the programming in the art
and then does the designer writing yes
it's a two-person team so you wouldn't
expect much but like I say like it
hasn't even seen this and we just played
like a week ago
so things come quick I think the first
time I saw the game it was just that one
kind of open entreaty garden area like
that's it this is a lot of new stuff in
just a couple more fun a dumb bird
before are we sure you're gonna win this
battle we don't know probably not we'll
find out I do have a good well you've
got like a squad now yeah I've got three
three bullets on my team you Doug and
Julia they're also kind of all dressed
up like they are in a game matching hats
and sunglasses such as sharks take that
number look at these guys wearing the
same stuff yes basically Clockwork
Orange
yeah good booth going back to the Milky
like
cookie fence are you gonna be happy
about this cookie claws no yeah his
eyebrows perpetually slanted like them
never happy and new Oobleck seed wheat
yeah cool uh yeah so uh did you wanna
move to another game out option so
that's all it's it's early in
development so but it'll be eventually
come out on PC you see and
if you see an Xbox one cool yes awesome
yeah Greg is gonna cue up the next game
nice and bikes I'm not mistaken that's
correct cool yeah
and knights and bikes has a really
interesting pedigree because one of the
former developers Rex Crowley right yeah
we're gonna terrorist proud it's not two
copies or they have some other um I mean
there's also musicians have to say yeah
but um yeah this is made my foam sword
which is a developer which is rest crawl
and mu you who work together at Media
Molecule and Rex credit airway and his
art style you'll recognize I think is a
really distinctive look and it's a
really beautiful game and it's a lot
inspired it's kind of autobiographical
like inspired by his childhood and
overflying oh man we're in gonna play
with me co-op okay so wait telugu movies
and girls names again Demelza and Nessa
own adventures fighting nights you can
write any what you if we have these
amazing bikes I can do this if I can
skit out yeah yeah and we we ride around
and we people have been disappearing
from the island and we've got to find
out what's up with that and restore
order
just like Rex do had to do when he was a
child how would you describe this game
it's an action-adventure co-op um you
can play you play single-player with the
AI but you can also play it both locally
co-op and also online okay yeah this art
style is really great yeah and that's
Rex drawing every single thing in the
game by himself we're going out there
you're wrong as moving out I didn't feel
like I am - yeah if I'm a bike is that
is that like a stamina thing yeah yeah
that's you pedal do that you'll
eventually okay
grow like my title you connected here
the problem - yeah well maybe I'm just
really bad advice to your Demelza right
to help you funny good over here all
right
go for it okay but yes we're off we
talked about Goonies a lot as an
inspiration - so like little kids on a
grand adventure that's potentially
partially actually dangerous but also
lots of fun made-up adventures along the
way yeah and this one's still pretty
early in development I think the first
time we saw this was was not that long
ago as well
I would probably been like PSX last year
um yeah and it's a it's actually coming
on pretty quickly
those guys are pro so they move fast but
this should be also something like 2018
as well okay so we just reached the end
of our little bike ride here gonna hop
off so the game kind of alternates
between these biking sections and now
area is on foot we have attacks I have
it I can kick up dirt I can smash the
ground and I can throw a long-range I'm
more like a ranged enemy or ranged
character so I have balloons and then I
also have larger ones that'll make
puddles clean co-op I can smashing her
puddles smashed her area two extra water
damage and there's a big woodpecker over
there
it's burning I hope it's nothing bad the
librarian so this is part of the
kidnapping plot begins ah you're in the
fire
[Laughter]
one of the things that I think is really
intriguing about this not just the art
style which immediately draws you in but
the story is also kind of dark and a lot
of moons yeah it's true for how pretty
it looks and how nice it looks it does
have this kind of a serious undertone as
well like the kids have problems and
they have asthma and they're bullied and
things like that move but you know
they're they're ultimately heroes right
out on an adventure triumphing yeah our
style just kind of like oozing nostalgia
at least to me
whoo-hoo yeah this whole opening area is
kind of like a road
theme park I guess the likes of which
are pretty common in Cornwall things
like the world's largest ball of yarn or
whatever but just kind of these decrepit
old roadside stands that still exist but
seem like they're falling apart it's
obviously in my area Jack the game is
mostly co-op but Toby little things like
this it'll happen kind of went off
suddenly we're in a race because kids
like to make up games on the fly
impulsively mmm-hmm Oh dad can you play
the game on your own as well or do you
always have to have a co-op companion
there is AI so you can't play
single-player but it's obviously more
fun with with a buddy Kevin plainly clay
he always loses rings Oh we'll see you
I just ate you with a water boy enjoy it
we're gonna fight each other on this
race I don't know no char coat just
gonna close uh-oh these Foam swords are
not innocent harmless Foam swords but
deadly center desk by a sentient foam
towards and on fire
our sorts danger zone is my shirt if you
lay down a puddle I think you just smash
this puddle come over here you guys
Oh Oh the blanks they're very aggressive
ace is it or no not necessary mmm
what she's standing still just looks
dumbfounded you know they both have a
lot of personality
yeah and strong different personalities
which is fun it's nice that it's kind of
reflected in their combat - right
demelza's more kind of running indie in
the middle of a situation just stomping
and kicking around where else a slide
stands back and throws our balloons from
a from a distance do the elements play
into your attacks as well are you able
to change that out like or are you
always kind of having water based
attacks no so there will be other
abilities we don't typically call them
attacks because it's not really like
just kicking she's kicking dirt up so
it's a little bit more child-friendly
but
there'll be different abilities and the
idea is that in general are trying to
make them all as much as possible really
focus on the coop abilities too so
Justin used to attack kids with dirt so
I think he's just kind of looking I said
mm-hmm you'll get to bully things I was
a really big bully in school I mean
probably tell give off that vibe stood
on your management yeah does that to me
every day help more stories and those
little yellow glowy things we keep
picking up are the currency for the game
and it's just kind of what most we
consider trash but to a kid little
treasures so little worms and bits of
trash bags and things like that that
eventually you'll use to kind of barter
for upgrades on your bike in this fun
little system I just got claws and a
worm there you go we got it so this was
showed off at at PSX but does that mean
it's a ps4 PC exclusive or is this
coming to Xbox as well yeah so they did
a Kickstarter about a year ago for the
project and they announced ps4 and PC as
part of that so those are definitely
coming and then that'll be launch
platforms and hopefully more after that
it's cool yeah yeah did you guys want to
move on to gang beasts now that we've
seen some on Knights and bikes this is
just my dredge for real violence yeah
slowly building to punching each other
in the faces sweet gang beasts is one
we're very familiar with at the GameSpot
office we have it look I do a lot of
fights with this one yeah it has changed
a lot over the years this is probably a
digital Damone's it's been rebuilt
basically like four or five times for
various reasons firstly performance but
then we've been working on online
multiplayer for a long time so that kind
of meant having to go back and retouch
everything but it's getting close to
actually being out on ps4 and and
releasing in full-on on PC as well I'm
going to a new mode today we're gonna
show you a new mode ever before it's
good up here so there might have been
like prior versions of this and like pre
alphas and things but now this is the
real waves mode so yeah kind of like a
survival mode if you hit X here you
should be able to jump in this is one of
the newer things too so these are you
characters that have been customized a
little bit more so there's now a
character customization tool and these
are like the presets that we've made
through that but ultimately they'll be
you know hundreds of different costume
pieces that you can throw onto your
character right I'm gonna go with be the
luge oh you already got that I'll be
started or obviously this is the first
game I played all week yeah nice up here
yes three your coat hanger here the
game's downstairs surrounded by them and
I couldn't get my hands on anything it's
we're all we're on a team now so colors
aren't going to matter I think we're all
gonna probably be blue but we'll be kind
of defending waves of enemy AI or it's
here uh so throw them in the fire Tim
just for your information there's a
little bit of a delay on our I Fiji out
of water upright gameplay off thank you
my gas formants level every millisecond
matters this red is bad right that's the
XFX me I'm blue I'm the cat I'm thinking
yes that's me I'm blue yeah guys are
this kind of ambience here at the top we
gotta get him got some shirts so I'm my
answer up I'm good don't hurt me mmm so
you got a bad guy there folks
so bumpers punch if you hold them they
grab and hold and then X jump says a few
other little things why makes your arms
go up in the air so oh okay if you grab
someone you can pick them up sometimes
yeah yeah get over here
yeah you got he throwing you in the fire
don't jump it right there that's my kid
eyes wait yeah
ah close so we can still grab each other
at a oh yeah no don't I'm not trying
this is the guy that plays rocket League
and all he does is try to blow people up
here we go oh uh uh I died Hey he tried
to drag me down yeah yeah I got all kin
I don't so you guys have to take him on
now three on one
all right he's down get him get him get
him
oh gosh oh my god yeah yes
all right wave one died that's good
honey people is that t-rex costume was
confusing I know sir no Kenny's gonna
lure you out all dee dee my neck the
whole thing survival-based
sick oh you guys got to do it three I'm
sorry here equal numbers I don't know
which one I am
oh they're all the glowing blue dudes
yeah neon blue I got a kind of thing
about Freeman yeah well he knock yeah
take it I knock him out yeah there we go
all right one down then all right it is
oh yes oh I'm kidding
wonderful yes are you out hell you're
behind three I don't know yeah let's try
my tire I'll do a good start for me
it'll be kind of fun if you got to come
back
everybody's or if you get - OH - fight
you like a fire there you go octoman
come on push you ain't got a peek amigo
you got so hot shout circle will be your
head but that's actually a key knockout
move okay
especially you jump and head butt or
jumping stick with your square okay and
my big dude
not him there he's like a giant cop or
something I can't even grow an elbow
that's this guy major paid at least they
don't these guys throwing punches like
Oh God
except me throwing elbows
yeah I think cops beating up on me yeah
so that big guy looking at me drill riot
just help me out
no there's a guy chasing me you have a
uses half a size oh my god getting
picked on I - no god oh god Justin oh no
no aah
okay all right all right already we're
both alive I might want to double team
that big guy yeah I gotta find kick well
I'm not ducking head bottom I think I'm
trying to headbutt him I'm just pushing
my face into the stomach yeah the big
guy might be hard to headbutt you have
to jump on him I got it I got idea okay
I got it come here give me a big yeah
just yeah yeah what is worth it is it
with me all right that one yeah I got a
Justin Tucker gonna give away try to get
to a three oh that's higham Hagen oh
you're not knocked out that was LM uh oh
I thought you meant you found the fire
huh you're alive no no yeah right all
right get justice and tell you is good
like five guys coming at you dude
yeah I've just been kind of hanging out
in the corner and doing nothing well
yeah that's tops no jolly oh gosh
there's two up top god this just in the
song man I don't know about this city
girl trying to pick you up and drag you
to the fire yeah I think they're going
to I think you might I didn't really
tasty flames huh no they're not working
together very well then No in their
defense I don't think we were either oh
they're coming I can get them to fall
into the fire maybe they're you where
you got one I got one
yeah thank you for some wannabe it's all
part of my part the strategy guide don't
just fall in lost that's really fallen
leaves book that was falsifying um do
you want to move on to show some second
oz - I think we have a very little thing
- cool from Seiken awesome so that was a
waves mode in gang beasts yeah cool and
I never machine be seen never becae
never be seen by human by eyes or sweet
so that was a first look at waves uh
yeah we're gonna cue up this yeah so
seconds we just did an update for our
backers or me you know
still you know early in production and
we are not showing a lot of our levels
and stuff what we showed near as the new
version of what razz looks like we uh we
can show ya go ahead and roll
we can talk around talk over it yes much
just um this is you know in this game
we're going to not a summer camp but
Raza's the headquarters of the
Psychonauts and here the idea is that he
is still wearing his iconic helmet but
he is now he will he'll actually loses
his clothes in a series of hilarious
hijinks and then has to find some old
clothes of Sascha's which a little too
big for him but you know he's always
admired sasha and ii nuts and wanted to
dress like Sasha and so the ultimate
he's actually using uh such as close to
the gang these guys are still fighting
away but Adam game he's really yeah
white boxing new levels and we have some
brains that are just on production but
that's seconds to awesome do you have a
release window for that yeah it'll be a
while working on yeah that was boots
alright yeah we watched Oobleck first
and then we're won't played some nights
and bikes beautiful and then played some
Gaby's horrifying and then we just saw
the near as and second us too um yeah
that was good yeah you're on point for
obviously thumbs up for all this yeah
what
well Greg rice tim schafer as always a
pleasure thank you for closing out
wednesday with us yeah take that
Wednesday one day with you
one and a half I don't know and a half
the air already uno logon three years oh
well I hope you guys enjoy the rest your
show okay thanks man see you around them
thanks for having us again watching
you're watching from home we will be
having more developer interviews and
gameplay demos from up here on the stage
and downstairs in our co-op stage
throughout the week so make be sure to
stay tuned we'll see you then
you